[Music]
just feel like there's no point anymore
I call me well let's go on any more
dates you don't want to know what it's
like out there you deserve someone so
it's so nice and everyone I meet is
either a psychopath or a freak they're
all weirdos oh my god do you read the
jack jack oh my god it's so even like
I'm trying to be that picky I just want
someone who's friendly and kind he
doesn't have to be loaded he doesn't
have to be really good-looking he just
has to be nice well I guess it's like
12-hour days and it's good that's
amazing I mean it's amazing you juggle
so many different responsibilities at
work it and how you dirt oh I don't know
it's something major it's just how it is
really it's just everyday well I'm
certainly impressed Thanks
[Music]
you
it was just everywhere it was
unbelievable
that's so bad it was gross there's a
second yeah it's lovely
I really enjoyed today maybe too
sorry I realized I stupidly arranged
that I'm gonna be somewhere else that's
right it's like have sex and yeah there
was it was I had a great time I'll text
you yeah yeah how's work then hmm yeah
it's all right it's fine like I think I
might drop down to four days definitely
he's taking someone else on so maybe I
could definitely yeah but it's so boring
anyway it's home about you tell me what
you been up to well I went on that date
last week okay yeah with that guy
yeah Graham remember yeah yeah yeah it
was good you're not sure no we I had a
good time okay yeah he's nice right I
was it pleased for you yeah
[Music]
hey hey how are you yeah I'm good what's
going on yeah I just wondered if you
fancied meeting up or hanging out with
something oh yeah I could hang out maybe
in a couple of days see I'm going to
Berlin for a few weeks
but yeah I'll let you know when I'm back
give me a call
ya know cool do it
Thanks
[Music]
[Music]
hey how're you getting along
yeah no that's okay that's that's fine
honestly i-i understand great I'll ask
you to see
[Music]
if you liked this film download our app
where you can view all our videos read
articles from the Book of Life and chats
with other students of the School of
Life